herzlich willkommen zur folge 187 das
faz einspruch podcast der wöchentlichen
podcast der faz für recht justiz und
politik heute am 24 november
2021 mein name ist corinna budras ich
bin berlin korrespondent in der faz und
mit dabei ist wieder
pia lorenz 9 ich bin freier journalisten
und juristen papier und heute bleibt uns
nichts anderes übrig als uns wieder
komplett fast komplett der korona lage
zu widmen die zeiten sind immer so
genau die zeiten sind so wir teilen mit
was heute wir zeichnen auf am mittwoch
den 24 10 11 in kraft tritt was er jetzt
unbedingt wissen müsst und dann hat
corinna gesprochen mit thorsten kingreen
über all die fragen die sich sozusagen
auf einer zweiten ebene stellen denn das
gesetz das jetzt in kraft getreten es
wird doch auch noch eine menge fragen
auf und außerdem habt ihr doch bestimmt
über die impfpflicht gesprochen das
haben wir in der tat rauf und runter gar
nicht so einfach ja kann man vielleicht
hier schon mal sagen lassen
sondern was schönes mitgebrachte du hast
immer wieder er in den fussball rhein
gestürzt
wieso derart gut wenn man denn den bock
zum gärtner macht und ich dann schon
wieder irgendwie ein bisschen fußball
mache aber tatsächlich habe ich mir
einmal angeschaut da es ja der fc bayern
yoshiaki mich wohl teilweise sein gehalt
gestrichen hat weil das schon zum
zweiten mal in quarantäne gekommen ist
und außerdem ist der trainer von werder
bremen zurück getreten und sein co
trainer sogar auch es steht im raum dass
im pässe gefälscht da ist es wirklich
ein skandal an den nächsten das alles
wirst du uns näher bringen und dann
haben wir ja dann sind wir auch schon
bei den nachträgen die gar nicht so
relevant sind dieses mal denn unter
anderem ist der sogenannte langsame
richter wohl final vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht
der hat uns in der tat auch schon öfter
beschäftigt und dann haben wir natürlich
noch ein gerechtes urteil das übrigens
auf mehreren hörer vorschlägen beruht
also auch da wieder herzlichen dank für
im brut ist immer wieder schön da drauf
gestoßen zu werden kann ich ja bei der
gelegenheit auch noch wir sagen wo man
das tun kann am besten unter der
e-mailadresse einspruch podcast
faz.de da freuen wir uns auch sehr über
anmerkungen kritik
belehrung durchaus auch kommt er hin und
wieder auch mal vor und ihm vorschläge
für gerechte urteile
[Musik]
so damit gingen wir doch jetzt mal mit
unserem corona block und am besten
starten wir mit einer kleinen szene aus
der parlamentsdebatte im deutschen
bundestag vergangene woche zum neuen
infektionsschutzgesetz und diese kleine
szene verdeutlicht ziemlich klar wie
groß die verwirrung selbst unter dem
bundestagsabgeordneten ist die ja über
dieses gesetz abstimmen mussten wir
hören einen kleinen schlagabtausch
zwischen dem unions politiker jan marco
luczak und dem spd politiker dirk wiese
viel spaß nach ihrem gesetz würde es
nicht möglich sein restaurants zu
schließen nach ihrem gesetzentwurf wird
es nicht möglich sein gastronomie zu
schließen nach ihrem gesetzt und so wird
es nicht möglich sein bars und clubs zu
schließen nach ihrem gesetzentwurf wird
es nicht möglich sein veranstaltung zu
untersagen all das wird nicht möglich
sein und ihm ist die auch selbst dass es
nicht ausreicht frau doktor like herr
doktor lutz sie kennen die
gesetzesvorlagen licht das muss sich
eindeutig sagen
das was sie hier streuen sind
falschinformationen
diskotheken und clubs können nach der
rechtslage die wir auf den weg bringen
soll den ländern geschlossen werde alles
was sie hier suggeriert ist falsch
so also das hat uns schon einmal sehr
gut eingeführt handy problematik in die
verwirrung die es gibt wir werden sie
gleich auflösen aber
vielleicht beginnen wir erst mal mit dem
was der doch wahrscheinlich alle oder
die meisten von unseren hörerinnen und
hörern beschäftigt nämlich die neue
dreijährige am arbeitsplatz bzw 3g im
öffentlichen nahverkehr was geht denn da
seit heute genau das sind die regeln die
jetzt quasi ab heute sofort ja
wahrscheinlich die allermeisten von uns
betreffen weil die allermeisten von uns
arbeiten gehen und wo möglich auch mit
öffentlichen verkehrsmittel dahin fahren
es geht los damit dass sie vielleicht am
liebsten gar nicht mehr fahren sollten
weil jetzt sehr deutlich wieder im
gesetz steht es geht zurück ins home
office die unternehmen müssen jetzt
wieder ihren beschäftigten home office
anbieten wo das irgendwie möglich ist
und die mitarbeiter dann müssen das
angebot auch annehmen wenn dafür
ihrerseits keinen berechtigten gründe
entgegenstehen ich könnte mir allerdings
vorstellen dass das so manchem
unternehmen jetzt etwas leichter fällt
als sogar noch in der letzten hochphase
der pandemie als ja eigentlich das
home-office auch schon galt man doch
auch sehr vielen unternehmen noch gehört
hat dass das nun ja nicht ganz so
beachtet wurde wie es vielleicht hätte
beachtet werden sollen denn ab jetzt
gilt am arbeitsplatz die dreijährige man
muss also geimpft chinesen oder getesten
sein und die arbeitgeber müssen die
einhaltung dieser drei gierige täglich
kontrollieren und dokumentieren also die
können durchaus auch von den zuständigen
behörden aufgefordert werden da war es
vorzulegen man kann das natürlich
sinnvollerweise so machen dass da wo man
es weiß dass die leute geimpft sind man
die daten hinterlegt so dass die nicht
mehr täglich irgendwie sich ausweisen
nun das dürfe aber ihr jetzt die
arbeitgeber optimal auf den rauen zu
verweisen da hatten wir das hier rauf
und runter diskutiert
denn es ist ja ehrlich gesagt schon seit
spätestens sommer ein thema das
eigentlich 3g kommen sollte ist es dann
nicht mehr weil wir erinnern uns die spd
da interveniert hat aufgeheizte
gewerkschaften das war alles ein
bisschen zu heikel
datenschutzrecht und auch durchaus auf
geheiß der datenschutzrechtlichen haben
sich da auch relativ stein negativ
reagieren weil ich weiss noch da habe
ich persönlich auch mit dem
bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten
oder ich kever konferiert zu bzw hatten
austausch der hat immer explizit gesagt
ihr könnt das machen ihr müsst es nur
verankern im gesetz und wir bitten euch
auch dies zu tun nur tatsächlich hat
sich die politik dagegen entschieden so
war die gemengelage im sommer also das
war alles eben ein riesen treffe vor
allem auf druck der gewerkschaften und
dann hat man gesagt machen wir nicht und
jetzt ist es dann doch sehr unauffällig
und immerhin zuge neuer höchststände
einfach mal mit ins gesicht die
beschäftigten müssen jetzt den den
impfstatus offenlegen in dem rahmen in
dem das nötig ist das kann hinterlegt
werden muss nach spätestens sechs
monaten von den unternehmen wieder
gelöscht werden aber wichtig darum ging
es daneben auch immer das darf auch
verwendet werden für die anpassung von
hygiene konzepten weil ja eigentlich
auch schon seit ein paar monaten in den
arbeitsschutz verordnungen drin steht
man kann die hygiene konzepte anpassen
daran so zu sagen wie gefährlich es ist
in den büros und wenn du jetzt zum
beispiel in dem großraumbüro in dem
ohnehin nur drei leute sitzen und die
alle drei geimpft sind dann kannst du
natürlich da schon ein anderes hygiene
konzept erstellen als wenn du irgendwie
mit 20 leuten einem relativ kleinen raum
sitzt von den zehn nicht geimpft sind
das heißt das darf man jetzt alles das
darf man auch berücksichtigen wie gesagt
löschung nach sechs monaten es soll aber
noch eine verordnung aus dem
bundesministerium für arbeit und
soziales geben die nähere regelungen
dazu ich glaube das ist eine sehr
lustige formulierung die tatsächlich
auch sehr weitreichend klingt also im
grunde genommen kann
hubertus heil der womöglich auch der
neue bundesarbeitsminister sein wird
ziemlich klar vorschreiben wie dann auch
dieses arbeitsverhältnis
ausgestaltet werden kann unter drei
gehen da dachte ich auch so hoch das ist
ja doch eine sehr weite formulierung wer
weiß was da alles natürlich schauen wie
weit er gehen wird es tendenziell schon
irgendwie zurückhaltend also ist ja nun
mal doch noch ein spd geführtes
ministerium und in aller regel geben die
sich ja schon mir da jetzt nicht völlig
irgendwie zu lassen aber hier ganz im
gegenteil arbeiten
genau so und damit die arbeitnehmer wenn
sie dann doch ins office müssen auch mit
der bahn fahren sicher ab heute im
öffentlichen personennahverkehr im
personenfernverkehr und im flugverkehr
also eigentlich überall wenn man nicht
mit dem eigenen pkw oder mit einem taxi
fährt und dann mit dem 3g oder
motorisiert motorisiert ich präsidiere
genau gilt jetzt 3g ausnahme sind
schülerinnen und schüler weil man eben
davon ausgeht dass sie in der schule
getestet werden man muss den infratest
nachweis jetzt also bei sich führen auch
bei der masken pflicht bleibe die
ausnahmen darf denn der sein das muss
nicht tagesaktuellen seine sondern ich
glaube 24 stunden oder also insofern
eine erleichterung man kann das dann
immer dann abends machen oder wie muss
man sich das vorstellen
ja meine ich auch ich bin mir aber gar
nicht sicher ob es tote detailliert im
gesetz geregelt also ich meine ich haben
darüber gestolpert das er 24 stunden
stand ein test der nicht älter als 24
stunden ist und hatte dann auch gedacht
das ist wahrscheinlich wahnsinnig
arbeitnehmerfreundlich war dieser hektik
macht möchte man sich jetzt nicht
morgens noch mal vorstellen
ja das wird interessant und kontrolliert
werden soll ist von tatsächlich den bahn
mitarbeitern bzw den s bahn mitarbeiter
nun ein leader genau das wird vermutlich
auch gar nicht so easy going wenn ich
mein werter in anderen ländern relativ
einfach sein könnte weil daher zum teil
an den u-bahnhöfen und so man überhaupt
nur zutritt hat weil man durch diese
schranken geht ist es ja in den
deutschen bahnhöfen in aller regel nicht
so also die deutsche bahn hat zum
beispiel schon gesagt irgendwie wir
werden das nicht irgendwie am bahnhof
kontrollieren sondern in den zügen denn
die pflicht gilt ja auch in den zügen
und wer dann im zug einen nachweis
vorweist muss am nächsten halt
aussteigen dort können die kontrolle
obwohl auch die bundespolizei um
unterstützung bitten und kann man dann
einfach in den nächsten zug wieder
einsteigen in der hoffnung dass es dann
keine kontrolle gibt das ist ja eine
gefahr da kann man natürlich versuchen
klar das werden bestimmt auch menschen
machen allerdings hat die deutsche bahn
gesagt wir werden das direkt mit staat
mittwoch auf über 400 strecken
kontrollieren also inwieweit das dann
wirklich kontrolliert werden kann auch
zum beispiel jetzt in den in den städten
im personennahverkehr und ganz ehrlich
schwer zu sagen aber es soll wohl massiv
mehr kontrolliert werden als jedenfalls
jeder ist ja auch dringend notwendig
hätten wir das zu diesen beiden aspekten
die uns alle sehr nahe betreffen das ist
es und ich würde sagen alles was
komplexer ist komplizierter und sich
womöglich in wenigen wochen schon wieder
änderte sprichst du jetzt mit thorsten
kingreen genau so machen wir das
was die bundesländer noch dürfen und
bald nicht mehr dürfen möchte ich nun
mit thorsten kingreen besprechen in
sachen corona war ja schon mal zu gast
in unserem podcast er ist professor für
öffentliches recht sozialrecht und
gesundheitsrecht an der universität
regensburg und hat die weiterentwicklung
des infektionsschutzgesetzes in den
vergangenen eineinhalb jahren immer
wieder auch als experte in den
anhörungen des bundestages begleitet
schön dass sich die zeit nehmen hecking
ring guten morgen herr motors die
verwirrung über die neuen regeln ebbte
nicht ab sogar unter den abgeordneten
wir haben es eben gerade gehört deshalb
wollen wir uns jetzt mal ganz
systematisch durch die neuen regeln
graben die epidemische lage ist ja nun
ausgelaufen ab heute gelten die neuen
regeln beginnen wir mal damit was nun
bundesweit gilt das ist diese typische
strauß von von regelungen masken pflicht
abstandsgebot usw die jetzt auch ohne
epidemische lage überall gelten können
genau also der der maßnahmenkatalog des
28 absatz 1 ist zwar mit der aufhebung
der evo damit der nichtverlängerung der
akademischen lager muss man ja sagen
grundsätzlich nicht mehr aktivierbar
aber es gibt diverse
handlungsmöglichkeiten der länder
und das wurde sozusagen in einem neuen
absatz 7 genau definiert was jetzt
darunter fällt
genau die länder können also der absatz
7 der senat die erste zugang mal zu den
rechten der länder an der absatz 7
ermöglicht es ihnen eben diverse
maßnahmen auch nach ende der
epidemischen lage weiter zu ergreifen
und es werden nur bestimmte maßnahmen
auslands beschränkungen untersagung der
sportausübung und insbesondere die
schließung von einzelhandel von schulen
und universitäten die werden
ausgeschlossen also das was man so
klassischerweise unterlag dort genau das
ist ja auch eine interessante gesetzes
systematiken hier werden sozusagen
verbote untersagt
interessanterweise das geht ihm jetzt
nicht mehr genau so werden dem verbot
untersagt vorher war so dass zu verboten
verpflichtet wurde das war auch eine
etwas ungewöhnliche gesetzt insgesamt
sehen wir glaube ich das bin alles
hoffentlich bald vorbei ist wie das
gesetz einfach mal vernünftig
überarbeiten lassen genau also das wird
jetzt immer deutlicher denn es ist nicht
schöner geworden
durch die neue regelung was aber auch
sehr neu ist in dem gesetz sind jetzt
ausdrücklich
rechtliche grundlagen für gt2 und gt3
ja genau also diese 2g 3g regelungen
oder dem g2 g3 je nachdem wie man es
nimmt die art ist er tatsächlich so
nicht gegeben und das hat zu erheblichen
rechtsunsicherheiten geführt und das ist
eine der erzieherinnen und verbesserung
dieser gesetzentwurf hat
sie hat vielleicht auch hin und wieder
mal ganz hilfreich genau darauf
hinzuweisen wie hat denn übrigens
vielleicht noch mal als verständnis
frage hamburg ist ja schon war sehr früh
dabei ich glaube das geht schon seit
über monate die 2g regelungen da auf
welcher basis haben sie das gestützt
ja das hat hamburg sehr sportlich auf
die allgemeinen regelungen des 21 absatz
1 gestützt in der sache hat hamburg zu
den richtigen weg beschritten und es
wäre gut gewesen wenn einige länder das
ebenso zu gemacht hätten und vielleicht
auch konsequenter als ist jetzt noch
bayern macht also von daher war die wahl
die rechtsgrundlagen vorher um es
vorsichtig zu sagen
sie sind jetzt da aber der weg war
richtig also verwirrung sorgt ja auch
dass es immer in der diskussion war dass
es einige maßnahmen künftig nicht mehr
geben soll sie haben schon gesagt
konkret geht es um ausgangs beschränkung
und einen flächendeckenden
lockdown also schließen von restaurants
hotels oder auch schulen so und jetzt
haben wir arbeiten die interessante
situation dass in bayern sachsen und ich
glaube auch einen seit 19
trotzdem genau das passiert also in
bayern zb gibt es einen locker und in
einigen hotspot kreisen mit in sidenten
jenseits der 1000 das ist ja ein
bisschen erklärungsbedürftig worauf
stützen sich die länder bei diesen
maßnahmen
ja das ist jetzt wiederum für nicht
juristen und nichtjuristen tatsächlich
kaum noch nachvollziehbar und mein
eindruck ist auch dass einige
kolleginnen und kollegen das jetzt noch
nicht so ganz verstanden haben es ist
auch leider sehr kompliziert tatsächlich
gibt es außer dem absatz 7 das 28 und
jetzt auch noch einen 28 absatz 9 und er
sagt dass alle maßnahmen die
gewissermaßen bis zum heutigen tage das
müssten wir heute oder gestern das ist
noch nicht so ganz klar kommt auch an
beim jetzt genau die epidemische lage
auslöst so wie ich interpretiere läuft
sie morgen aus das heißt an maßnahmen
die noch heute ergriffen werden auf der
grundlage des paragrafen 28 absatz 1
können haben geld noch bis zum 15 12 das
heißt bis alle maßnahmen die auch alle
lockdown maßnahmen die jetzt in den in
den verordnungen der länder stehen
haben noch gültigkeit bis zum 15 12 20
21 und damit hängt ja dann auch zusammen
das ja das evaluiert werden soll das war
ja der komponist in der verhandlung
genau wo es ergibt sich denn eigentlich
diese fünfzehnter dezember der steht
tatsächlich nur selbst steht im gesetz
macht dass man sie als 9 steht drin dass
der absatz 1 28 also das ganze locker
und instrumentarium auch nach dem ende
der epidemischen lage bis zum ablauf des
15 dezember in kraft bleibt wenn bis zu
dem tag des festivals beschlusses also
heute noch entsprechende maßnahmen
ergriffen worden also bestehen da jetzt
letztlich natürlich die bundesländer
etwas im regen die jetzt maßnahme noch
nicht ergriffen haben
möglicherweise auch gerade im norden und
westen von deutschland in der erwartung
das ist ohnehin nicht so schlimm kommen
werde aber im prinzip wäre dass man
fällig wenn man jetzt aus der
perspektive der länder schaut und die
möglichst ihr ganzes instrumentarium
sicherheitshalber vorhalten wollen
sinnvoll dass jedes land seine
rechtsverordnung entsprechend auch ab
ändert dann hat man zumindest bis zum 15
12 noch das ganze instrumentarium
vielleicht reden wir noch darüber ob das
wirklich sinnvoll die hand und ganz
andere frage können wir gleich hier an
dieser stelle machen weil ich dass er in
der tat auch eine interessante
konstellation er denn eigentlich war ja
der feste wille der ampel koalition auch
ehrlich gesagt über die drei partner
hinweg dass man als einfach den
instrumentenkasten ausmistet nun hat man
ihn am anfang zu weit ausgemistet muss
man ja doch deutlich sagen also es wurde
ja schon erheblich nachgebessert dann
das kam mir noch später hinzu zum
beispiel die dreijährige am arbeitsplatz
und die dreijährige in den öffentlichen
im öffentlichen nahverkehr es wurde auch
es gab auch noch noch nachschärfung was
die länder noch zusätzlich über ihre
länderparlamente
einfügen können dazu kommen wir gleich
aber letztendlich ist das natürlich eine
sehr halbherzige regelung jetzt nur dass
man hat im grunde noch eine
fristverlängerung gewährt bis zum 15 12
wobei man sich ja darauf fragen kann
naja also aber die pandemie wird jetzt
in drei wochen wahrscheinlich auch immer
noch nicht vorbei sein
ja man muss sagen das ganze ist einfach
natürlich nicht gut gelaufen aber man
muss sich auch fragen wie man das
eigentlich vorwerfen kann und um das
sozusagen auch vom anfang aufzudröseln
also die dreijährige am arbeitsplatz in
den öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln die ist
ja in der vergangenen kollektionen nicht
durchsichtig dass er ja sozusagen der
maßnahme gewesen die man ergreifen
können zweitens die länder hatten und
haben theoretisch hatten sie bis zum
gestrigen tag der geist ja noch das alte
recht die möglichkeit alle maßnahmen zu
ergreifen die sie ergreifen wollten die
die möglichkeit bestanden nach immer und
sie haben das noch nicht getan wir haben
aber auf der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz am 22.10
ausdrücklich gesagt sie wollten von der
länderklausel hier ist ja da noch gar
nicht gebraucht mal an dass man
sozusagen als erst die klinken sie kurz
die länder klar sind noch mal erklären
länderklausel sagt 20 absatz 7 die alte
dass auch nach auslaufen der
epidemischen lage die länder alle
maßnahmen ergreifen können die sich für
erforderlich halten wenn ihr
landesparlament das beschließt die an
also noch die komplette freiheit den
ganzen katalog weiterlaufen zu lassen
wenn sie das gewollt hätten aber sie
haben ihnen gesagt so das wollen sie
nicht auch weil einige bundesländer die
verantwortung nicht übernehmen wollten
beziehungsweise mangels mehrheit in den
landesparlamenten vielleicht auch nicht
übernehmen konnten in den kleinen
gefährten ländern haben wir ja auch
teilweise etwas politisch instabile
koalition und deshalb war das relativ
wohlfeil dann die verantwortung auf den
bund zu abzuladen das muss man damit
zunächst mal sagen dass das letztlich
ein teil des problems ist dass da auch
verantwortung hin und her geschoben
wurde also am 22 oktober hat man sich
klar gegen die länderklausel entschieden
er auf der anderen seite wurden ja dann
immer mehr die stimmen laut die immer
wieder forderten dass man dann doch an
der epidemischen lage von nationaler
tragweite
festhalten soll und deswegen kam es
jetzt zu diesen punktuellen änderungen
die er dann doch ja signifikante
veränderungen vorsehen also will sagen
zum beispiel die tatsache dass man jetzt
die einzelnen länder jetzt schon bis zum
15 12 da waren wir stehen geblieben die
regeln verlängern können auch die
harschen regeln wie kontakt
beschränkungen wie ausgangssperren wie
flächendeckenden lockt downs und
schulschließung dass die sind möglich
bis zum 15 12
und sie hatten schon erwähnt am
9.12 trifft man sich wieder daran darauf
haben sich bund und länder
geeinigt und man hallo irrt was bis
dahin passiert ist na ja ich muss sie
vielleicht in einem punkt muss ich muss
man muss noch präziser sein die sind
diese maßnahmen die sogenannten locked
down maßnahmen sind nicht bis zum 15 12
möglich sondern sie wird ein bisschen
zwölften sie bis heute ergriffen
wir wollen doch noch dran machen dann
ist es zu spät haben man in diesem
absatz 9 der ist halt gekommen durch die
durch die dramatische entwicklung die
diejenigen die dann in die ampel im
oktober natürlich so nicht vorhergesehen
hat das muss man ganz klar sagen da ist
eine gute idee letztlich zum falschen
zeitpunkt
etabliert wurde genau auch eine wichtige
präzisierung also die länder müssen sich
beeilen das bis heute müssen sie sich
entscheiden hopp oder topp welchen
maßnahmenkatalog wollen sie und dieser
maßnahmenkatalog geht dann bis zum 15 12
was meinen sie denn was passiert am 9 12
also wenn der evaluiert wird diskutieren
wird das dann alles wieder von vorne
oder womit rechnen sie
also in einer pandemie 15 tage nach
vorne zu gucken das haben wir glaube ich
alle schlagen die möglichkeit ich weiß
nicht womit ich rechnen soll aber
es wird natürlich wir werden am 19 12
nicht in der situation sein das war eine
entspannte lage haben und das nicht
schon damit dass die diskussion wieder
kommen wird allerdings müssen die länder
auch genau präzise sagen was sie denn
eigentlich wollen obersten gesetz fehlt
und es ist durchaus vorstellbar dass man
etwa den absatz das datum absatz 9
dann noch um einen oder zwei monate
verlängert das heißt die maßnahmen die
dann ergriffen worden sind noch sonst
eigentlich nur bis zum 15 dezember
sondern bis zum 15 jahren oder 15
februar gelten das wäre ja durchaus
denkbar das nützt allerdings natürlich
denjenigen ländern die die maßnahmen
nicht bis heute ergriffen haben ja das
ist sozusagen das noch nachschärfen
ich finde es trotzdem wichtig das so zu
machen weil man macht deutlich ist
bleibt dann ein übergangs recht denn die
aufhebung der dänischen lage ist
grundsätzlich die ab not richtige
entscheidung
die vielleicht ein bisschen zu spät
kommen das ist ja ihr betitelung gewesen
dass man die vielleicht ein bisschen
früher hätte aufheben sollen im sommer
machen müssen ja gut
letztendlich wollte ich noch mal fragen
also wir haben jetzt die situation dass
wir tatsächlich 3
ich glaube drei bundesländer haben die
jetzt da von diesem erweiterten
instrumentenkasten oder von dem eigen
instrumentenkasten so möchte diesmal
formulieren
gebrauch machen die anderen
konzentrieren sich alle im wesentlichen
auf 2g 3g 2g plus wenn ich das richtig
gesehen habe und auf die maßnahmen die
dann tatsächlich zur verfügung stehen
noch
genau das machen die anderen länder in
der tat und das ist ja auch die die
nachhaltigste lösung ja weil wir sagen
muss diese die länder die jetzt in den
hotspots noch den alten
instrumentenkasten wie sie das nennen
anwenden machen das ja auch grund einer
akrobatischen situation denn letztlich
führt natürlich jetzt einen lock down
oder ein teil auch darüber dass nennt
das war sicherlich dazu dass
infektionszahlen sinken aber das
bedeutet nicht sinkt die
impfbereitschaft ja die leute sagen naja
wenn jeder doktorand kommt sollte ich
mich dann impfen lassen denn im grunde
kommt man mir aus der pandemie nur aus
durch eine erhöhung der impfquote und
nicht durch dauernde lockdown da kommen
wir übrigens auch gleich nach zu
vielleicht noch eine frage die
bundesländer die jetzt nicht die
epidemische lager ausgerufen haben kam
die denn ansonsten gar keine
möglichkeiten noch weitere dinge zu
verhängen oder haben die geht es über
das länderparlament auch noch anders ja
die länder die das jetzt dem von dem
absatz 9 also von dieser notfall klaute
denn ich sie mal nicht gebrauch gemacht
haben haben ja dauerhaft die möglichkeit
nach absatz 8 jetzt weitere
schutzmaßnahmen ja das ist möglich dass
der absatz 8 lässt er den ländern die
möglichkeit auch ohne unabhängig von
einem datum bestimmte schutzmaßnahmen zu
ergreifen es werden eben nur die
genannten schutzmaßnahmen die ohnehin
fragwürdigen ausgangs beschränkungen die
aus meiner sicht auch sehr
die schulschließung sowas wird
ausgenommen aber die länder haben ja das
instrumentarium prinzipiell wenn das
landesparlament das so sieht weiterhin
in der hand mit ausnahme in der dort der
dort genannten
maßnahmen und das bedeutet konkret zum
beispiel die schließung von freizeit wie
wir es in einrichtungen der
freizeitgestaltung so heißt es glaube
ich na also konkret discos und bars na
da sind sie wieder die dürfen
geschlossen werden ja genau weiß ich das
ganz genau angucken also ausgeschlossen
sind ja die nummer 11 bis 14 da müsste
man jetzt mal im detail nämlich welche
darunter wenn ich es richtig sehe das
ist ein bisschen komisch die bars fallen
glaubt unter gastronomische einrichtung
werden die sie nennen das noch discos
von meinen kindern das ist doch clubs
richtig genau das alles ja nur noch
klubs die fallen offenbar die können sie
tatsächlich schießen weil die keine
gastronomischen einrichtungen sind das
ist ein bisschen komisch und
eine schicht sondern greifen damit
zusammen sollen belehren lassen dass im
clubs getanzt wird und was mich ja genau
ich meine
die differenzierung lässt sich ja sogar
hören im gegensatz zu den alle
differenzierung die wir schon gut also
um das vielleicht noch mal zusammen zu
fassen also wir haben jetzt tatsächlich
in
einigen bundesländern eine lage die uns
sehr sehr bekannt vorkommt nämlich wo
alles also mit quasi mit dem holzhammer
versucht wird die situation noch zu
retten mit dem instrumentarium was wir
aus dem vergangenen herbst und winter
und frühling kennen dann gibt es die
große masse der anderen bundesländer die
sich konzentrieren auf zwei g2 g + 3g
und auf die gezielte schließung von
einzelnen einrichtungen weil das muss
man übrigens vielleicht auch noch mal
deutlich sagen das wird ja weiterhin
möglich sein wenn es irgendwo quasi ein
ausdruck gegeben hat zum beispiel in
einer schule dann wird die natürlich
auch vorübergehend dichtgemacht eben nur
nicht mehr alle richtig das kann das ist
dann der einzelmaßnahmen das kann dann
sogar auf grundlage von paragraf 28
erfolgen so gar nicht den 28 a da
könnten sie natürlich wie sie das auch
schon früher konnten bei einem
massenausbruch in der schule natürlich
vorübergehend mal die schule tatsächlich
schließen oder den betrieb jedenfalls
verringern im übrigen was ganz wichtig
ist die länder könnten auch weiterhin
kontakt beschränkungen vergänglicher sie
sind ja noch reingekommen in den katalog
der weiter hinten länder der meinung
sind dass sie das brauchen das machen
können im übrigen selbst für so shares
held selbst für geimpfte
das ist auch normal ein wichtiger
hinweis zweiter hat es in der
vergangenen woche auch so ein bisschen
aufregung gegebene also dass da wohnen
immer kontakt beschränkungen
ausgangssperren in einem atemzug genannt
vielleicht sollte man an dieser stelle
nochmal erklären dass ja letztendlich
die ausgangssperren für sich genommen
also ein sehr zweifelhaften epidemischen
erfolg aufweisen weil das man kann sich
genug szenarien ausdenken wo leute
alleine auf der straße sind auch nachts
alleine auf der straße sind und wo da
keine probleme keine ansteckung zu
identifizieren würde aber die ausgangs
beschränkungen dienten im wesentlichen
dazu die kontakt beschränkungen zu
überprüfen das war jetzt das was wir im
vergangenen jahr gesehen haben war eine
sehr wackelige konstruktion um das in
aller vorsicht zu sagen aber das war
jedenfalls sowohl es begründet und wie
gesagt die kontakt beschränkungen sind
ja weiter möglich dass das mal herr
lindner in einem atemzug genannt hat und
dass dann alle so über ihn hergefallen
sind habe ich jetzt persönlich ein
bisschen übertrieben er hat es ja dann
richtig gestellt dass man tatsächlich in
kontakt und ausgangs beschränkung
[Musik]
genau für die die es nicht kennen und
die ist vielleicht nicht so intensiv
verfolgt haben da gab es ein interview
bei den tagesthemen soweit ich weiß nie
wo tatsächlich herr linder der
fdp-vorsitzende die beiden in einen topf
geworfen hat und gesagt hat kontakt
beschränkungen und aus
er hat es nicht nicht so in den mund
genommen aber man konnte sagen wir so
auch sein
äußerungen verstehen dass er meint dass
kontakt beschränkung und ausgangssperren
daran nicht wirksam sind zur bekämpfung
von einer epidemischen lage und das muss
man für die kontakt beschränkungen
natürlich anders sehen denn die sind
schon durchaus sehr wirksam nur lassen
sie sich eben sehr schwer überprüfen
vielleicht kommen wir noch mal zu den
neuen schwellenwerten auch das ist ja
wirklich ganz interessant dass es etwas
was bei den bund länder beim bund länder
treffen überhaupt erst vereinbart wurde
da gibt es eben schwellenwerte die
beginn bei einem schwellenwert von 3 der
hospitalisierung rate da gibt es eine
flächendeckende
zweig regelung
stimmt dass zwei regelungen
flächendeckende zweit geht nicht wenn
ich das vielleicht kurz das ohne
bayern hat den ganzen einzelnen also
ausgenommen ist
ja das ist wirklich sehr völlig
unverständlich in bayern gibt es den
einzelhandel nur eine quadratmeter
begrenzt und aber noch nicht mal eine 3g
regelungen ja also das ist wirklich ich
habe sie nur deshalb unterbrochen weil
ich finde das zeigt sehr gut wieder
sozusagen ein arbeit massiv polizei
politik gemacht wird so nach dem motto
wir haben nicht genug instrumente aber
die instrumente die da sind und die
wirklich effektiv sind ja und geht's bei
effektiv wird sie auch in bereitschaft
aus die werden nicht konsequent
angewendet und die aus dem tal easy russ
rate also der schwellenwert von 3 ist
übrigens auch in einen bundesländern
überschritten das heißt eigentlich
müssten wird eine flächendeckende zweig
regelung sehen und die geht auch
automatisch na also da muss im grunde
genommen in den bundesländern gar nichts
verhängt werden oder lassen naja sagen
wir so also
die bundesländer müssen dass in ihrem
das ist ja nur politisch
getan worden
quasi
gesetzliche regelungen
so umsetzen wie es ihm gerade gefällt
haben das wäre anders gewesen wenn man
es wie bei der bundesnotarkammer
[Musik]
das warum man denn die ausbilder wenn
man nicht gerade den stellenwert also
was mit den maßgeblichen wert ist für
die auslösung der maßnahmen warum dann
nicht gleich ins gesetz geschrieben hat
zb in bayern da kann ich es jetzt noch
einigermaßen boten so und ich glaube
auch in den anderen hotspot
bundesländern dass letztlich die reihe
sieben tage incidence wieder maßgebend
dafür ist weg gemacht ausgelöst werden
und welche nicht das macht es natürlich
sehr kompliziert weil eigentlich keiner
mehr genau durchschaut um welche werte
es eigentlich gehen und die ostsee der
hospitalisierung wert allein maßgebend
ist was ja offenbar fachlich kritisiert
wird dann so hätte man das auch besser
ins gesetz geschrieben so kann das jeder
machen es politisch verabredet worden
aber so seien rechtlich verpflichtend
ist das natürlich nicht ja auch da
wieder interessant dass auch in der
berichterstattung die hospitalisierung
skate eigentlich eher eine
untergeordnete rolle spielt also wir
haben immer noch tatsächlich ins tänzen
die in den allen meldungen auftauchen
und das was eigentlich es vereinbart
wurde taucht gar nicht auf ich würde
kurz noch mal die reihe zu ende machen
also wir hatten beim schwellenwert von 3
die zweige regelungen wir haben bei
einem beim überschreiten des
schwellenwertes von sechs die regelung
zweig bloß ne also genießen geimpft plus
im schnitt es das reicht aus man muss
nicht unbedingt einen pcr-test sein und
dann haben wir noch den schwellenwert
von neun wenn der überschritten ist dann
geht die länderöffnungsklausel
also dann können weitere
mithilfe der landesparlamente weitere
maßnahmen beschlossen werden also so
habe ich das auch verstanden wo bei
ihnen klar sagen muss mich sind
maßgebend rechtsnormen und nicht so sehr
politische vereinbarung die ja dann noch
eine rechtsnorm gewänder umgesetzt
werden müssen das ist nochmal worden
aber wie gesagt von den vereinbarungen
hat bayern zum teil auch so misst bayern
zum teil schon wieder abgewichen
recht schnell kommen wir doch jetzt
nochmal zur impfpflicht sie ist ja auch
ein heißes eisen sie wird eigentlich in
den letzten tagen sehr vehement
diskutiert und auch so dass man sich
tatsächlich vorstellen kann dass daraus
auch etwas wird also im gegensatz zu den
ständigen beteuerungen die wir jetzt
über ein jahr gehört haben dass es keine
impfpflicht geben wird ändert sich ja
jetzt im moment das blatt und da würde
mich natürlich auch die rechtliche
einordnung erst mal interessieren
vielleicht beginnen wenn man auch damit
dem was wahrscheinlich relativ einfach
sein dürfte nämlich die
berufsspezifische
impfpflicht also zb bundeswehr hat jetzt
schon angekündigt da das wird in den die
korona schutzimpfungen wird in den
katalog der schutzimpfung der
verpflichtenden schutzimpfungen
aufgenommen die es ja schon gibt also
konkret zum beispiel gegen tetanus oder
auch gelbfieber dann haben wir noch bei
der polizei wird diskutiert bei
pflegeberufen krankenhaus und lehrer und
erzieher wie würden sie da die
rechtliche einordnung beschreiben also
wenn sie mit wenn sie sagen die
berufsbezogene impfpflicht ist die
einfachste ich hoffe mich dann finde es
die schwierigste
weil man sich genau überlegen also erst
mal haben wir da wieder dass die
gleichheits frage wie nehmen wir den
jetzt ein und wählen die nicht rein bei
soldaten geht es uns ja schon immer
kronast jetzt nur das programm mit
aufgenommen oder sollen das programm mit
aufgenommen werden aber die grenzen ja
eigentlich die die personen den
personenkreis update dieser impfpflicht
unterliegt also wir hören jetzt hatte
ich immer von personal in pflegeheimen
und in den krankenhäusern
aber das müsste ja wohl auch die
arzthelfer und arzthelferin erfassen
dann natürlich so geschah auch die ärzte
und ich glaube tatsächlich dass es in
der jetzigen situation eher schwierig
sein wird einen bestimmten kreis von
leuten und zwar ausgerechnet diejenigen
die in der pandemie im moment sehr den
kopf für uns alle immer halten jetzt
auch noch heraus zugreifen und so was
kann ja sehr schnell zu einem blumigen
changing führen und da halte ich jetzt
nicht so sehr viel von also wenn man das
machen möchte sollte man lieber ganz
machen und auch da habe ich bedenken
kinder können wir gleich zu kommen nur
eine ein argument dass er in diesem
zusammenhang häufig genannt wird und ich
finde das verfängt durchaus auch als sie
haben natürlich recht dass die sich
besonders abgearbeitet haben aber die
sind ja auch noch einmal besonders nah
dran an den variablen gruppen als ich da
da ergibt sich ja schon die
rechtfertigung quasi aus der beruflichen
tätigkeit
richtig aber der 79 ich sehe das genauso
nicht sind das sind für mich bleibt das
auch natürlich als sozusagen bürger
völlig unverständlich dass sich menschen
die in den groben arbeiten ist eben
verlassen das was ich aber mir scheint
die abgrenzung ganz schwierig zu sein
ich denke auch an dem psychotherapeuten
der ja auch durchaus minerale personen
nach einer krebs op behandelt der müsste
dann auch einer entschließung der liga
muss sich sehr genau überlegen was sind
das eigentlich alles für berufsgruppen
und wenn man dann eher in die details
geht wird man sich kompliziert ist und
das sozusagen zu neuen debatten führt
und auch damit er auch zur spaltung die
moment jetzt vielleicht nicht das
geboten was ich sagen sie aber sind denn
das jetzt eher politische bedenken oder
gesellschaftliche denken die sie da
bedenken die sie vorbringen oder sind
das auch rechtliche bedenken ja das ist
ne also die frage jetzt wenn sie weiter
bei der berufsbezogenen hinten liebler
sehr schnell zu rechtlichen bedenken
werden wenn man gewissermaßen eine
bestimmte gruppe raus nimmt und eine
andere nicht also dann fangen wir einmal
bei allen differenzierten
behandlungen
erklärt worden nachdem und da muss man
sich natürlich dann fragen ob man so
etwas riskieren will ja da ist die
impfpflicht dann zur alle jedenfalls
über 18 sicherlich gleichheits rechtlich
der sichere
also da würde wäre dann artikel 3
wenigstens nicht wirklich und das stimmt
auch vielleicht um das noch mal deutlich
zu sagen was da abgewogen werden muss
das ist einerseits natürlich der
eingriff in die körperliche
unversehrtheit
heute die da immer von den im kritikern
und impfgegnern angeführt wird also
durch die spritze es ist eben nicht nur
einfach die blutabnahme oder so sondern
es wird ja tatsächlich passiert ja was
im körper das ist das grundrecht was die
kritiker einführen ein bring- und das
muss abgewogen werden gegenüber der
schutzpflicht des staates die gesundheit
seiner mitbürger zu schützen ist das in
etwa so genau das ist sozusagen damit
ich beschreiben sie sozusagen das
prüfungsprogramm obersten gericht
anliegen würde wenn das eine impfpflicht
prüfen und da ist natürlich der
knackpunkt auch immer die
verhältnismäßigkeit der maßnahme wie wir
es ja auch schon bei corona rauf und
runter gesehen haben sie haben jetzt
eben artikel 3 genannt was jetzt die die
wehr die unterschiede zwischen den
berufsgruppen angeht aber letztendlich
ist wahrscheinlich auch eine diskussion
die dann zumindest geführt werden müsste
ob das das mildere mittel da steht
ja also grundsätzlich muss man mal sagen
entschied ist ganz generell sagt was uns
rechtlich zulässig das ist erstmal ganz
wichtig dass das auch deutlich wird das
ist schon früh durch das
bundesverwaltungsgericht festgestellt
worden und jetzt im übrigen auch noch
mal für uns durchaus auch relevant durch
eine entscheidung des europäischen
gerichtshof für menschenrechte im
frühjahr dieses jahres
das problem ist in der tat die
erforderlichkeit im einzelfall ich würde
sogar schon einen schritt weiter gehen
vorher ansetzen bei der geeignetheit
weil man sicher fahren muss oder wenn
man etwas nicht den eindruck erwecken
als würde die impfpflicht für die
jetzige bälle irgendetwas bringen ja
also eine impfpflicht die man ja moment
schon mangels
erforderlicher ins möglichkeiten gar
nicht durchsetzen könnte könnte man ja
allenfalls du das studio etabliert man
könnte also sagen auch erst 2022 muss
jeder geimpft sein und um damit eine
fünfte welle zu verändern und das geht
auch für dich berufsspezifische
impfpflicht
naja man muss das ja sozusagen gesetzt
sich erstmal regeln und dann muss man ja
den leuten erst mal die ganze zeit
lassen bis
auch wirken ja also von daher man darf
wirklich nicht den eindruck erwecken was
würde jetzt irgend eine impfpflicht
gegen diese vierte welle helfen ja das
ist das ist einfach falsch oder wenn man
das ziel ausgibt wir wollen folgende
wählen also 56 und hoffentlich dann gar
keine mehr verhindern dann in der tat
ist das jedenfalls eine geeignete
maßnahme weil es führt kein weg über die
immunisierung ja also wir können noch
mal immer wieder lockt downs jahren
gehen die zahlen der unter die leute
werden nicht wie man durch dr
und deswegen also wir werden der bis zur
immunisierung ist zentral und dann kann
natürlich eine impfpflicht die dann
sozusagen die nächste welle verhindert
auch geeignet sein weil der
erforderlichkeit und die hatten sie ja
jetzt gerade angesprochen da ist es
natürlich immer erforderlich dass man
zeigt dass man nicht alle möglichen
mittel ergriffen hat andere mittel und
dazu muss ich noch mal sagen die haben
ja in 2g gar keine chance bisher gegeben
zwei gegend gerade erst an und dass die
zahlen hoch gehen und mein eindruck ist
moment wir müssen alle nicht nur
individuell vernünftig sein also noch
kollektiv geduldig ja das hilft leider
moment nichts das ist nun mal so dass
dauerten jüngster zeit lang ist diese
impfung dann wirken werden das wird
nicht in drei vier wochen der fall sein
ja leider leider weil wir eben letztlich
ja wir haben unsere infrastrukturen
sommer abgebaut wir haben zu spät mit
dem boostern begonnen dass das alles ein
eher politisch administratives versagen
dass er aber jetzt durch so eine akute
watte nicht mehr einholen kann aber
letztendlich wenn man das alles so
zugrunde legt und auch die langfristige
perspektive
annimmt dann könnte man schon zum
ergebnis kommen wenn also je nachdem wie
sich jetzt in der tat zwei gehe
ausgewirkt hat das einfach wir dann wenn
alles nichts hilft im frühjahr eine
allgemeine impfpflicht
implementieren könnten ja dass das auf
jeden fall in der tat wenn wir jetzt
über den sommer über den winter
feststellen dass das nichts geholfen hat
dann werden wir dann ist auch nicht
herumkommen das sehe ich ganz genauso ja
das ist also nicht das thema wir dürfen
nur nicht den eindruck erwecken als
würde ich jetzt hilfen helfen mein
eindruck ist eher dass das jetzt
kontraproduktiv wirkt wo menschen im
angesicht der katastrophe und anders
kann man das ja nicht nennen jetzt doch
endlich zur besinnung kommen und sich
impfen lassen
möchte ich das zu sehen menschen sind
leider wir sind leider alle fünf nach
zwölf menschen warten
politik nicht anders das war wie kann
man denn eigentlich so eine impfpflicht
dann und setzen welche sanktionen wären
denkbar ja also man kann impfpflicht
umsätzen natürlich indem man an die
nichterfüllung der pflicht erst mal ein
bußgeld
an mit einem bußgeld bewehrt man kann
sich aber auch gefahren für rechtlich
durchsetzen etwa durch zwangsgelder
songs gelder an den charme dass man sie
auch öfter verhängen kann damit fliegt
dann immer noch nicht erfüllt wird kann
man so 20 grad auch noch mal verlängern
was ich mir was natürlich juristisch
oder politisch sagt diesmal ein
theoretisch auch möglich ist den
sogenannten unmittelbaren zwang
anzuwenden
ich vermag aber nicht vorzustellen dass
wir menschen mit polizeilicher gewalt im
ins zentrum des herren da muss man
einfach sagen da hat der demokratische
rechtsstaat bestimmte mittel einfach
nicht zur verfügung
das muss man einfach so anerkennen
machen das kann ich wirklich nicht
empfehlen so weit zu denken sondern mit
finanziellen zwangsmitteln oder muskel
dann kann man das tun aber anders nicht
die aber ehrlich gesagt auch
zwangsgelder bzw bußgelder können ja
dann auch durch haftstrafen durchaus
ersetzt werden fall von großer renitenz
dass das muss man muss man in der tat
überlegen ob man das dann tatsächlich
macht ja die sogenannte zwangshaft ist
ja sogar möglich ja dass man
gewissermaßen durch inhaftierung
jemanden dazu versucht zu veranlassen
das verhalten was er zudem verpflichtet
werden soll dann auch tatsächlich in die
tat umzusetzen
aber ich halte das für eine sehr
theoretische debatte um mögliche nacht
wurde auch sagen diese debatten würde
ich nicht führen in einer zeit wo wir
gerade noch mal versuchen menschen vor
dem hintergrund einfach der furchtbaren
situation geradezu überzeugen bitte
lasst euch impfen das ist vielleicht
auch ein wichtiger hinweis geht das ist
auch in der vergangenheit glaube ich ein
bisschen schief gelaufen also ich finde
in der kommunikation war es ja immer
entweder so dass gesagt wurde dass
überhaupt gar keinen druck aufgebaut
wurde das immer gesagt hat dass ein
absolut freie entscheidung und so weiter
und jeder kann machen was was man will
dass bei dass man aktiv der des ersten
jahres quasi noch sogar der ersten
anderthalb jahren und jetzt schwingt man
sozusagen um und nimmt sieht das andere
das andere ende und redet dann gleich
davon oder baut als mögliches szenario
auf das dann allerdings auch gleich
abgelehnt wird von zb
gesundheitsminister sparen der dann in
einer pressekonferenz gesagt hat naja
wie können ja die leute dann auch nicht
mit der polizei impfen lassen oder
abführen und zum im zentrum bringen
lassen aber das wiederum wäre ja auch
nur das andere extrem nah und dazwischen
muss man ja sagen gibt es ja noch viele
viele grautöne also man kann vielleicht
wie sie jetzt auch öfter getan wird von
einer moralischen pflicht sprechen man
kann auch durchaus das als pflicht
formulieren ohne erstmal sanktionen an
zu führen und dann die sanktionen eben
tatsächlich er in einem weiteren schritt
er über bußgelder beziehungsweise
zwangsgelder laufen lassen gibt sehr
viele schattierungen letztendlich
den grautönen haben wir da wahnsinnig
mir schwer in schwierigkeiten er hat in
der tat wir haben erst von der zwillings
freiheit gesprochen und jetzt kommt ein
ganz den ich auch schwieriges an den
pranger stellen von ungenutzten auch das
sollte man also werden da auch mal
rhetorisch wieder abrüsten müssen
sondern einfach sagen müssen die haben
ja bestimmte ja anreizsysteme die dazu
führen werden dass menschen sich impfen
lassen und wir sagen dass von diensten
eine größere gefahr ausgeht und wir
deshalb selbstverständlich auch gegen
ihnen gegenüber andere maßnahmen
ergreifen dürfen was gegenüber gästen
als ich das aber im sommer mal in einem
beitrag vorgeschlagen habe habe ich
unendlich viele hassmails bis 17
strafandrohung von strafanzeigen und ich
würde mich an der grössten
weltverschwörung beteiligen also sie
sehen wie diese debatte damals schon
aufgeladen war und das aber man hätte
eben viel früher anfangen müssen
tatsächlich mit diesen regelungen aber
ohne menschen an den pranger zu stellen
sondern einfach zu zeigen wir haben
jetzt zwei möglichkeiten kann sich
impfen lassen oder wir müssen
gefahrenabwehr bei dir
also da in der tat ist irgendwie sind
die grautöne verloren gegangen man hätte
ja zb wie gesagt auch schon früher mit
2g anfangen müssen aber stattdessen war
dann immer vom von der impfpflicht durch
die hintertür die rede vielleicht ein
karierter debatte vielleicht zuletzt
noch mal etwas zum organisatorischen
auch dass man kommt er hat ja im moment
ehrlich gesagt nicht den eindruck dass
der staat das überhaupt organisatorisch
hinbekommen würde 80 millionen auf also
relativ schnell zu impfen womöglich
sogar zweimal im jahr das ist auch eine
debatte die im moment überhaupt nicht
geführt wird wie weit die eigentlich
gehen soll wir haben ja jetzt die
diskussion wie lange überhaupt der
impfstoff an hält die wirkung des wind
impfstoff anhält wir haben jetzt erste
erkenntnisse die sind ja auch noch gar
nicht so alt ist das das über sechs
monate hinaus nicht ist wir haben
übrigens auf
europäischer ebene jetzt auch die
debatte wie lang diese im
zertifikate eigentlich halten sollen da
habe ich jetzt als heute als beispiel
oder als vorschlag gehört sechs monate
das heißt wir würden davon reden dass
wir auf richtung alle sechs monate
brauchen das bedeutet 160 millionen
impfdosen im jahr wir vielleicht mal
dass in perspektive zu setzen für die
118 millionen haben wir elf monate
gebraucht und da waren jetzt also im
moment liegen wir bei 118 millionen
impfdosen verabreicht wurden und davon
liefen natürlich die ersten monate sehr
schleppend aber wir hatten auch
tatsächlich sehr fette monate darunter
niveau es einfach sehr sehr schnell
gehen also das ist organisatorisch auch
noch mal vielleicht was anderes aber
zurück zu meiner frage welche ansprüche
hat in umgekehrter bürger eigentlich
gegenüber dem staat im falle eine
allgemeine impfpflicht er müsste doch
dann dafür sorgen der staat
auch geimpft werden kann und wenn das
eben nicht geht und man monatelang
keinen impfstoff bekommt gibt es dann
irgendwelche ansprüche die man umgekehrt
an den staat richten könnte naja also
der staat eine impfpflicht
in seinen gesetzen fest schreibt muss
man natürlich auch dafür sorgen dass
diese pflicht erfüllt war ist ja das ist
das gleiche wie mit der mit der
steuerpflicht wenn der staat ihnen keine
kontonummer nimmt
steuerpflicht nicht können sich ja schon
pflicht nachkommen ja der staat hat das
natürlich eine beibringung pflicht und
man wird in der tat dieses große
eindruck ihr programm was sie gerade
geschildert haben nur durch eine ganz
andere form der impfkampagne das
sozusagen heute systematisch
angeschrieben werden angedacht wird
gezeigt daran wie das etwa in spanien
passiert ist und natürlich durch die
wieder den wiederaufbau der impfzentren
schaffen was wenn niedergelassene ärzte
natürlich nicht schaffen ja diese
dimension und man wird natürlich auch
darüber nachdenken müssen ob man dann
doch die apotheker die ja bisher nicht
impfen können oder dürfen ob man die
nicht auch jetzt einbezieht in die
kampagne des nächsten jahres das geht
natürlich nicht so schnell die müssen
geschult werden ob es noch ein paar
rechtliche grundlagen haftungsfragen
geklärt werden aber auch die apotheker
wird man dann im jahr 2022 einbeziehen
müssen es wäre gut wenn wir da jetzt
sogar nachdenken würde und nicht erst im
nächsten sommer wenn dann die gibt dritt
oder editiert oder 5 ja gut also noch
viel zu tun in kingreen ich danke sehr
herzlich dass sie mit uns mal diese doch
recht diffizile lage aufgedröselt haben
ja ich bedanke mich das nette gespräch
so also dass zu den neuen alten länder
kompetenzen und dem was uns da in den
nächsten wochen monaten vielleicht noch
blüht aber jetzt gucken wir mal auch den
fußball videos immer so gerne mafia was
war da los
wir haben zwei geschichten aus dem
fußball ich fange an mit user käme ich
der ist ja vor einigen wochen was wär s
und 1 grad
das ist ein spieler vom fc bayern und
zwar sogar ein sehr bekannter spieler
der wohl auch eine gewisse
vorbildfunktion hat für die jugend von
heute auch innerhalb der mannschaft usw
um so entgeistert da war man als vor
einigen wochen heraus kam dass er sich
nicht hat impfen lassen weil er wohl
bedenken hat gegen die impfung das hat
er selber zugegeben muss man
ehrlicherweise sagen denn also hat er
auch genau also auch das hat er
öffentlich zu einfach so berichtete also
jetzt auch nicht schamhaft oder so
sondern hat einfach gesagt macht er
nicht weil er der bedenken hat wegen den
langzeitfolgen die angeblich noch nicht
bekannt sind also und einen sturm der
entrüstung brach und er ist wohl auch
nicht der einzige es gibt da wohl
irgendwie so so eine kleinere gruppe von
fünf oder sechs bayern spielen die alle
noch ungeimpft sind heute morgen kam
allerdings die information dass es bei
dieser bayern-spieler sich jetzt wohl
impfen haben lassen zumindest sich die
erste impfung haben verpassen lassen und
yusuke mich darüber nachdenkt dass jetzt
auch zu tun vielleicht liegt es ja daran
was in der letzten woche passiert das
wird jetzt immer live übertragen
wahrscheinlich die impfungen der
einzelnen bayern spielen dann kann man
sich vorstellen
ich glaube so ein gefährt die
vorbildfunktion darf man offensichtlich
nicht unterschätzen und ich glaube der
verein ist auch mittlerweile recht
genervt dass die durchstechereien bei
allem was sozusagen in die richtung geht
das auch der verein sich mühe gibt die
spieler dazu zu motivieren sich impfen
zu lassen jetzt relativ schnell seinen
weg in die medien
gut aber ich habe dich unterbrochen
wurde ist eigentlich sagen was letzte
woche so passiert ist erzählt doch mal
genau letzte woche war joshua king mich
wohl zum zweiten mal schon in quarantäne
und dann gab es bis heute nicht
dementierte berichte ich glaube zuerst
in der bild am sonntag dass der fc
bayern ihm und anderen spielern in
quarantäne anteilig gehalt gestrichen
hat für diese zeit und da haben wir uns
natürlich naheliegend für einen rechts
podcast gefragt geht das und die kurze
antwort lautet ja und zwar sogar relativ
unproblematisch also fußballspieler sind
arbeitnehmer dh bis auf ein paar
ausnahmeregelung gelten für die ganz
normale arbeitsrechtliche regelungen das
ist zum beispiel auch der grund dafür
dass stand heute die profispieler
überhaupt noch ungeimpft spielen dürfen
unten auf dem rasen weil nämlich quasi
auf dem rasen arbeitsrecht gilt es ist
ja für sie deren arbeitsort das heißt
dort gilt also maximal 3g im moment und
die fans die sind ja im rahmen ihrer
freizeitgestaltung unterwegs wo in aller
regel zwei gilt die dürfen deshalb nur
geimpft oder genießen in italien so und
jetzt seit oktober november haben viele
bundesländer ist umgesetzt dass
arbeitgeber gehälter kürzen können wenn
ungeimpft in quarantäne müssen wir haben
das relativ ausführlich vorgestellt in
der folge 178 jahr war es noch ein
bisschen unklarer als es heute ist ihr
könnt da gerne nochmal detailliert
reinhören heute und jetzt nur noch mal
so kurz als als update für die nächsten
kneipenbesuche wenn ihr vorbeischauen
geht damit ihr genau bescheid wisst und
das euren nicht juristischen freunden
erklären könnte es geht also nicht um
die entgeltfortzahlung im krankheitsfall
da wird man immer weiter bezahlt also
wenn man jetzt irgendwie corona symptome
hat dann kriegt man ganz normal weiter
geld sondern es geht und den fall dass
man in quarantäne muss also abgesondert
wird weil man mit einem infizierten
zusammen war ohne selbst symptome zu
haben dann kann man logischerweise auch
nicht arbeiten es sei denn man kann im
home office geht ja was hat übrigens
julia nagelsmann gemacht der trainer der
hat in santa der muss da auch in
quarantäne und der hat wohl irgendwie in
seiner küche dann sich so eine art
kommandozentrale aufgebaut hat aus dem
homeoffice trainiert das fand ich auch
sehr hübsch wenn man das nicht kann wer
nicht arbeitet kriegt kein geld das ist
im regelfall ein fall der unmöglichkeit
nach § 326 bürgerliches gesetzbuch
in corona zeiten wurde das geändert da
hat der staat gesagt wir schicken euch
in quarantäne also entschädigen wir euch
auch und dann haben die arbeitgeber dann
in der regel erstmal weiter gezahlt und
sich das geld dann vom staat zurück
geholt aber seit oktober november beruft
man sich auf den paragrafen 56 absatz 1
satz 4
infektionsschutzgesetz der regel dass
keine entschädigung bekommt wer durch
inanspruchnahme einer schutzimpfung
hätte vermeiden können dass er jetzt
nicht mehr arbeiten kann genauso und
dann waren die voraussetzungen erst mal
so ein bisschen streit wie ich hat man
sich überlegt ob er vielleicht der
paragraf 616 bgb dann irgendwie denen
gehaltsanspruch noch erhalten könnte das
vertritt eigentlich jetzt niemand mehr
sondern dieser zumindest der rechts
gedanke dass 56 fsg wird auf
arbeitsrecht komplett das heißt teile
der serie a klub natürlich habe ich mich
durchgesetzt ja ich habe doch immer wenn
ich also doch nur später ist auf jeden
fall ja ja auf mich hört ja sozusagen so
aber es ist jetzt klar dass kein gehalt
gezahlt werden muss wenn jemand
ungeimpft in quarantäne muss es war
allerdings dann so dass viele
unternehmen hin unter der hand gesagt
haben leute wir tun uns doch diesen
stress nicht an mit unseren
arbeitnehmern wenn es dann jetzt mal um
zehn tage geht dann haben wir da
riesenstreit im betrieb und vor allem
war da natürlich auch wieder das
datenschutzproblem akut dass wir vorhin
schon angesprochen hatten weil man ja
gar nicht final wusste ist denn jemand
jetzt ungeimpft nur wenn die leute das
nicht offen legen mussten was natürlich
relativ gut ist wenn ungeimpft zu sein
die voraussetzung dafür ist dass man die
läden und streicht so long story short
jetzt wussten wir dass joshua king mich
auf jeden fall ungeimpft war und der fc
bayern hatte jetzt wohl dann doch mal
irgendwie genug von dem ganzen trainer
auch ich nehme an von den medialen
treffe also nach medienberichten geht es
denn wenn joachim ich für eine woche in
quarantäne musste wo er vermutlich um
knapp 400.000 euro für ihn ich gehe
trotzdem davon aus dass das den fc
bayern für den fc bayern jetzt nicht den
ausschlag gegeben hat das zu tun sondern
die sind wohl sehr genervt von der
ganzen diskussion um mich und seine
vorbildfunktion musste dann kann ihnen
ja auch nicht einsetzen also was will
sie mit dem spieler der die ganze zeit
noch nicht mal auf der bank sitzt
sondern eben zu hause vorm fernseher
wenn möglich dann chips rest oder so
also ich finde dass nach dem stimmt
nicht so ungesunde sachen würden aber
will sagen das ist ja nun auch vor allen
dingen nicht das erste mal ich glaube es
war das zweite mal dass er war zum
zweiten mal in quarantäne und genau aus
diesem grund haben wir uns ja auch noch
gefragt ob dann nicht wenn man jetzt
irgendwie fünfmal hinter neuen
quarantäne müsste der arbeitgeber nicht
nur irgendwann sagen könnte mir reicht
das jetzt und ob man gekündigt werden
könnte und dazu habe ich mal kurz
gesprochen mit professor michael roth
einem fachanwalt für arbeitsrecht in
hamburg vielen vielen dank herr vor ort
für ihre wie immer unglaublich fixen und
detaillierten auskünfte shoutout an
michael von sozusagen
hervorgeht hält das für grundsätzlich
denkbar dass man arbeitnehmern
mittelfristig sozusagen kündigen könnte
aber für den bundesrat für den
spezialfall bundesligaspieler
wahrscheinlich am ende doch wieder nicht
also ich versuche es jetzt sehr kurz zu
machen doch sehr ausführlichen
überlegungen die hervor und mir
geschickt hatte also erhält aus zwei
gründen grundsätzlich für denkbar
nämlich erstens meine arbeit nehmen die
ihrer tätigkeit nicht mehr nachgehen
können weil sie umgeben sind also er hat
zum beispiel den kunden service
techniker genannt wer da nicht mehr bei
kunden rein darf oder so wenn man das
dann irgendwie mittelfristig nicht mehr
darf ja blöd sozusagen und der zweite
fall ist genau der demokrat angesprochen
dass corinna wenn der arbeitgeber wenn
der arbeitnehmer quasi immer wieder
ausfällt und der arbeitgeber dann
ständig fehlzeiten kompensieren muss was
natürlich irgendwie relativ nahe liegend
bei so einem fußballspieler so ist er
fällt ja dann auch nicht irgendwie mit
zwei wochen planbarkeit aus sondern
wahrscheinlich dann einen tag vorher
wenn es blöd läuft und zwar vor dem
super wichtigen bundesliga-spiel gegen
den bvb oder so kann ja alles keiner
wollen michael vor ort meint das könne
man vermutlich mit einer
krankheitsbedingten kündigung
vergleichen und sich dann überlegen gibt
es eine negative prognose
ja die gibt es dann vermutlich schon
weil man halt immer wieder in quarantäne
landen kann vor allem wenn mehrere nicht
geimpft sind im team und es kann wenn es
erhebliche betriebliche ablauf störungen
gibt und zumindest dann wenn man dem
spieler mal vor augen geführt hat dass
das vielleicht irgendwann die konsequenz
sein könnte also quasi so eine art
abmahnung aussprechen würde hält er das
eigentlich schon grundsätzlich für
möglich dass es mittelfristig in
bestimmten konstellation ein
kündigungsgrund sein kann wenn man
umgehen aber und hier kommt jetzt das
aber profifußball verträge sind
befristet das ist ein das ist ein ein
sachgrund aufgrund der arbeitsleistung 8
uhr an als das ist das teilzeit
befristungsgesetz das wird vom
bundesarbeitsgericht so akzeptiert und
in befristeten arbeitsverträgen sind
ohren zu kündigen und das wären beides
ordentliche kündigungsfälle in aller
regel ausgeschlossen und michael vor ort
sagte natürlich naja und am ende hat
natürlich auch kein vereinten interesse
daran ein spieler zu kündigen weil er
dann nämlich auch nicht mehr diese
enormen transfersummen bekommt ja wenn
er den verkaufen will
das ist denn das wäre dann glüht
deswegen für alle arbeitnehmenden da
draußen die ungeimpft sind überlegt euch
mal ob ihr einen unter einen dieser
vielfalt und ob das vielleicht
mittelfristig ein risiko sein könnte
dass ihr da sozusagen eine kündigung
riskiert überlegt euch sowieso dass es
natürlich immer sinnvoll ist sich impfen
zu lassen aber für die fußballer unter
also konkret jetzt hier so kimmich und
seine konsorten da beim fcb ist das wohl
keine gefahr dass jetzt also jetzt
hoffen wir natürlich sehr dass das
irgendwann mal in einer möglichen
prüfung auftaucht war jetzt so wunderbar
erklärt
also das vielleicht als kleine hinweis
ein die jura-professorin die uns
wirklich zuhören und die hohe studenten
also sehr schöne sehr schöner ausflug
auf den grünen platz aber das hätten wir
hier warten wir haben ja noch einem
entschuldige bitte natürlich nicht los
wir haben sogar doppelt grün denn die
nächste geschichte ist gott das ist ja
wirklich auch so unglaublich legt los ja
das ist wirklich ganz verrückt der
trainer von werder bremen ist am
freitagabend zurückgetreten das ist herr
markus anfangen der heißt wirklich so
genauso wie sein co trainer und gegen
beide besteht wo derselbe verdacht und
zwar der verdacht auf impfpass fälschung
die staatsanwaltschaft bremen hat am
montag weitere details heraus gegeben
warum sie diesen verdacht hat und zwar
ist markus anfang angeblich laut seinem
impfpass digitalen impfpass im
impfzentrum in köln geimpft wurden aber
seine daten wurden laut der
kassenärztlichen vereinigung also sagte
die staatsanwaltschaft an keinem der
beiden tage an denen er angeblich dort
gewesen sein soll irgendwie vom im
zentrum inter fand
und dann gibt es ja immer diese
chargennummern die in den impfpässe
nirgendwo vermerkt sind und eine dieser
angegebenen chargen wurde gar nicht
verimpft und die chargennummer des
zweiten angeblichen impftermin es ist
wohl verimpft worden aber nicht an den
tag das heißt es gibt jetzt definitiv
einige anhaltspunkte die darauf
hinweisen dass da zumindest irgendwas
nicht koscher ist das ist auch das was
die staatsanwaltschaft bestätigt hat und
dann gibt es noch eine menge
medienberichte unter anderem von ich
habe jetzt hier sekunde von der deich
stube das ist ein cent magazin wissen
von yahoo
es ist total soll kommen da wird's nicht
mehr steht da und die haben eben relativ
viel ermittelt war es der der
pressesprecher der staatsanwaltschaft
auch zwar nicht bestätigt aber auch
nicht dementiert hat mir gegenüber von
daher gebe ich euch das mit weil es
einfach schon ein wenig amüsant also bei
seinem vermeintlichen ärzten im ersten
termin in köln soll der herr anfang
eigentlich bei einem auswärtsspiel
gewesen sein und zwar in würzburg und
beim angeblichen zweiten impftermin soll
er im trainingslager im zillertal
gewesen sein also beides ist jetzt nicht
so ne ecke von köln dass man sagen
könnte realistisch dass er dort gewesen
ist und wir haben uns dann auch noch ein
bisschen gefragt wie sind ideen denn
eigentlich da irgendwie drauf haben und
fest steht dass die anzeige vom
gesundheitsamt in bremen und die sind
laut da ich stufe das es jetzt das wo
der staatsanwalt nicht dementiert hat
aber auch nicht bestätigt sind wohl
stutzig geworden weil es im november
eine kommune infektion gegeben hat im
spielerkader und dann mussten die
anderen eben quasi die impfpässe
vorlegen zur kontakt nachverfolgung und
da hat sich dieser mitarbeiter des
gesundheitsamtes gedacht moment mal da
war doch irgendwas weil eben die erste
impfung angeblich im april stattgefunden
hat markus anfang aber noch im juni
öffentlich gesagt hat er sein
hoffentlich gehst du dieses bisschen das
ist ja wirklich investigativ ja und noch
es gibt noch was investigatives es hat
wohl im august auch schon einen vorfall
gegeben es gab dann test der sich
nachträglich als negativ herausgestellt
hat aber da hat sich markus anfang nun
in quarantäne begeben obwohl er das als
geimpfter gar nicht gewusst hätte und da
wäre er aber laut offiziellen angaben
wäre durch games gewesen im juli und da
hätte er eigentlich schon eben nicht
mehr in garantie energien müssen und das
hat wohl dieser mitarbeiter des
gesundheitsamts irgendwie alles zusammen
gesetzt und dann haben die angefangen
darum zu forschen haben dann diesen
impfpass gecheckt der wohl auch relativ
gut gemacht war aber für experten war
dann doch relativ schnell sichtbar da
ist was was irgendwie nicht koscher ist
wie gesagt vieles davon ist auch
recherche der deich stube und anderer
medien und auch die kicker wird
natürlich viel berichtet aber die
staatsanwaltschaft hat jetzt eben
bestätigt dass die ermittelt und das sb
auch wirklich sehr große ungereimtheiten
gibt ermittlungen laufen wegen 279 also
§ 2 179 strafgesetzbuch der gebrauch
unrichtiger gesundheitszeugnisse das ist
eine der normandy mitwirkung zu heute er
jetzt auch geänderten wurden das haben
wir in der vorletzten freunde relativ
ausführlich gemacht und das dargestellt
aber für den fall markus anfang ist es
eine relevante änderungen denn die alte
rechtslage passte für ihn ja denn er hat
ja gegenüber dem gesundheitsamt ein
unrichtiges gesundheitszeugnis vorgelegt
wenn es denn unrichtig gewesen sein
sollte der natürlich gilt auch hier die
unschuldsvermutung markus anfang hat
sich nachdem er anfangs gesagt hat dass
er wohl ordnungsgemäß geimpft sei jetzt
nicht mehr geäußert sein verteidiger hat
akteneinsicht beantragt und laut dem
kicker wird wohl auch der
kontrollausschuss des deutschen
fußball-bundes jetzt gegen ihn ermitteln
da könnten also nicht nur strafrechtlich
sondern auch sportrechtliche sie wenn
sie zu kassieren ist ja echt auch noch
hochinteressante geschichte wie es dann
doch und heraus kommt also und wie
gesagt der co-trainer ist wohl auch
betroffen über den weiß man bisher
weniger der vorwurf ist aber den level
und er ist auch am freitagabend mit
zurückgetreten und man fragt sich ja
schon ein bisschen irgendwie wie viel
angst man eigentlich vor dieser impfung
haben kann wenn man sich all das antut
ja oder wieviel sozusagen
ja widerstandswillen man haben muss
gegenüber innenstadt angeht nicht
bevormundet also ist ja echt irre gut
wir werden sehen wie es weitergeht also
ich nehme an das wird dann
wahrscheinlich auch in einem
strafverfahren münden das womöglich dann
auch öffentlich ist ne wenn die
anhaltspunkte sich verdichten klar
solange sich keine gründe warum denn er
und das wird dann womöglich auch seine
wirkung entfalten ok dann machen wir
hier mal schluss mit fußball und kommen
zu den anderen themen
so wir haben noch zwei nachträge die uns
du uns auch jetzt näher bringt beginnen
wir doch mal mit der afg was gibt es
denn da neues
also das bringen wir euch mit sozusagen
aus gründen der chronistenpflicht weil
wir darüber schon mal kurz berichtet
hatten und zwar geht es um die berliner
fdp hat jetzt auch vor dem
oberverwaltungsgericht
berlin-brandenburg
verloren in sachen
verfassungsschutzbericht für 2020 da
hatte die berliner fdp beantragt dass es
dem land berlin verboten werden soll sie
als verdachtsfall einzuordnen und sie
mit nachrichtendienstlichen mitteln zu
beobachten und wie schon das
verwaltungsgericht hat jetzt auch das
oberverwaltungsgericht gesagt gibt es
nicht weil ihr nämlich gar nicht
hinreichend glaubhaft gemacht habe dass
ihr als extremistischer verdachtsfall
eingestuft werdet das ist darüber
berichte in der welt berliner morgenpost
gibt reicht dem oberverwaltungsgericht
nicht und die sagen eben interessante
argumentation der verfassungsschutz in
berlin müsse das auch nicht sozusagen
sich gegen sich gelten lassen er müsse
das auch nicht bestätigen oder
dementieren weil das auf eine
ausforschung hinaus ist natürlich ist
natürlich auch interessant ich meine das
ist natürlich schon nur noch halb so
effektiv wenn jemand weiß dass er
überwacht wird und
die nachrichtendienstliche beobachtung
ist genau dasselbe auch das sei eine
bloße spekulation der berliner afd und
wer spekuliert hat deshalb noch keinen
unterlassungsanspruch
allerdings hat die afg berlin in einem
punkt doch gewonnen das land berlin muss
eine pressemitteilung herausgeben in der
steht dass das verwaltungsgericht im dem
berliner verfassungsschutz verboten hat
die berichterstattung über den
sogenannten flügel der afg im
verfassungsschutzbericht
2020 da geht es natürlich darum dass
dieser flügel sich ja angeblich zum
ersten fünf 2020 aufgelöst hat aber
jedenfalls konnte der verfassungsschutz
das hatte schon das verwaltungsgericht
berlin im einstweiligen
rechtsschutzverfahren festgestellt keine
aktivitäten glaubhaft machen oder
belegen von anhängern dieses flügels
jetzt speziell in berlin speziell für
den berichtszeitraum
1020 das hat die verwaltung in berlin
auch schon brav gemacht da gibt es eine
ganz kurze pressemitteilung in der das
genauso drin
mit zwei sätzen ja richtig die ist auch
schon draußen aber da ist es ja dann
doch wichtig um sich auch gegen lügen
und lücken presse vorwürfe zu wehren
dass man diese dinge auch zu ende
berichtet deswegen haben wir euch das
noch kurz mitgebracht und wir haben noch
den langsamen richter
genau richtig über den haben und auch
lange lange unterhalten weil es ja in
der tat auch eine sehr interessante
konstellation ist also geht um die
unabhängigkeit des richters ne und wie
weit ihn rein regiert werden darf von
der vorgesetzten
bleibt den ganzen fall müssen wir nicht
mehr irgend groß erzählen in der geld
gab gab es etliche folgen dazu über den
langsamen richter aber wie ist es denn
jetzt ausgegangen
thomas schulte kellinghaus hat jetzt
verloren und zwar vermutlich auch final
verloren also der sc will richter am olg
karlsruhe am außen sitz in freiburg und
er hatte von seiner vorgesetzten eine
ermahnung bekommen und einen vorhalt
weil er das durchschnittliche erledigung
pensum von richtern ganz erheblich und
jenseits aller großzügig zu bemessen
toleranzbereich
unterschreite in bestimmten jahren habe
er weniger verfahren gemacht als ein
halbtax richter hieß es damals in diesem
vorhalt und hersteller besonders
gründlich hatte er gesagt genau herr
schulte kellinghaus hat immer gesagt ich
bin ich langsam ich bin gründlich und
hat gesagt diese rüge dir da bekommen
hat stelle einen eingriff in seine
richterliche unabhängigkeit da und du
hast es gerade sagt corinna ihr habt
darüber wahrscheinlich schon gesprochen
seit es diesen podcast gibt denn herr
schulte kellinghaus geht schon seit fast
zehn jahren mittlerweile gegen diese
rüge vor er war schon zweimal beim
dienst gerichtshof am olg stuttgart dann
war schon zweimal beim bgh ist schon
einmal beim bundesverfassungsgericht
zurückgeschickt wurden und das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat jetzt offen
gelassen ob grundsätzlich dieser vorhalt
und diese ermahnung seiner seiner chefin
den verfassungsrechtlichen anforderungen
an die richterliche unabhängigkeit voll
genügen und hat gesagt
schulte-kellinghaus hat einfach nicht
substantiiert dargelegt dass er
möglicherweise in seiner richterlichen
unabhängigkeit
beeinträchtigt wird denn also ich
versuche das einigermaßen
herunterzubrechen schulte-kellinghaus
hat jetzt nicht gesagt irgendwie dass
alle seine kolleginnen an denen er ja
gemessen wurde irgendwie schlechte
arbeit machen würden oder so sondern er
hat eben sozusagen gesagt ich kann nicht
mehr vernünftig richterlich ohne
eingeschränkt zu werden in meiner
richterlichen unabhängigkeit arbeiten
wenn ihr mir solche vorgaben macht aber
das bundesverfassungsgericht sagt nein
das hast du nicht nachvollziehbar
begründet das so zu sagen du diesen
vorhalt nur nachkommen könntest indem du
deine rechtsanwendung änderst am ende
ist das so ein bisschen auch die
bestätigung der rechtsprechung der
vorinstanzen die haben natürlich alle
gesagt naja eine änderung der
arbeitsweise wie sie deine ehemalige
vorgesetzte die bei herr schulte
kellinghaus gefordert hat das bedeutet
ja nicht zwingend dass du jetzt anders
entscheiden musst oder total dadurch
hetzen musst und irgendwie keine
fundstellen mehr nach gucken kannst oder
was auch immer sondern es kann ja auch
einfach heißen dass man mal
organisatorische aspekte angeht also es
kennt ja jeder irgendwie jeder hat
bestimmt schon mal mitarbeiter oder
kollegen gehabt wo man sagt das
zeitmanagement könnte vielleicht
irgendwie besser seien jedoch mal deine
zeitfresser an oder so und das hat am
ende jetzt das bundesverfassungsgericht
auch ein bisschen gesagt und hab gesagt
na ja also du hast nicht so richtig
dargelegt warum das eigentlich eine
einschränkung der richterlichen
unabhängigkeit sein sollte sondern es
kann ja auch einfach irgendwie bedeuten
dass du deine arbeitsweise in der
anderen richtung enders und deswegen
haben sie offen gelassen ob jetzt diese
rüge an sich eigentlich in ordnung war
und vielleicht in die richterliche
unabhängigkeit hätte eingreifen können
das dürfte tatsächlich auch das ende der
geschichte sein denn thomas schulte
kellinghaus geht weiter und dann wäre
jegliches feststellung interesse
seinerseits da wohl über die wo genau
und da wäre es ja auch schön wenn man
jetzt einfach mal die sache auch gut
sein lässt nach zehn jahren
rechtsstreitigkeit wir tun es jedenfalls
jetzt ne absolute
so dann komme ich jetzt noch zuhörer
post eine erfreuliche sache und eine
sache die wir vielleicht noch richtig
stellen müssen wir von mal mit dem mit
der vergangenen woche an und dem häuser
klar den wir hier so munter besprochen
haben ich kann dazu sagen wie carrie
tooway wie man so schön sagt er also in
der guy ganz schön gemengelagen die hier
wirklich sehr lustiger war und durchaus
auch
sehr
amüsant wenn man jetzt davon ausgeht
jedenfalls das ist ja gut ausgegangen
ist für dieses ehepaar haben wir
natürlich ein bisschen vergessen habe
ich natürlich vor allen dingen vergessen
so ein bisschen auf die besonderheiten
des immobilienkaufs und nochmal
zurückzukommen und zwar der clou war ja
vielleicht und das sollte man einmal
deutlich so sagen dass das ehepaar durch
diesen verkauf die ihr eigentum nicht
verloren hat also das war tatsächlich
das haus gehörte immer noch in sie waren
die rechtmäßigen eigentümer nur im
grundbuch war stand etwas anderes und da
kommt jetzt der clou durch den
weiterverkauf denn in solchen
konstellationen weil eben die des
grundbuchs hohen beweiswert hat es
ausnahmsweise mal möglich dass ein eine
immobilie gutgläubig erworben werden
kann ja also wenn es tatsächlich gelingt
dieses ding dann zu verscherbeln für
sechs oder sieben millionen euro so hoch
wie ihm der marktwert er war und
vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr drauf
her wie das heutzutage auch üblich ist
dann ist es eben wenn man da einen
gutgläubigen käufer findet erhält in
dieser situation ist es dann eben
möglich gutgläubig den den
den verkauf abzuwickeln das heißt dann
in diesem fall hätten dann die
eigentümer hätte das ehepaar ihr
eigentum verloren an den gutgläubigen
käufer so und wir waren jetzt in einer
so genannten er zwischen situation das
ist denen ja nicht gelungen das hat mir
beschrieben und deswegen gelang es auch
dem ehepaar dann durch eine grundbuch
berichtigung auch wieder quasi zurück
ins grundbuch zu kommen also das war
dann das wurde dann richtig da war denn
die sachlage danach klar und so auch wie
es den tatsachen entspricht aber das
sollte man vielleicht noch einmal
deutlich gesagt haben und das haben wir
glaube ich ihm vergangene woche nicht so
klar gemacht dagegen die terminologie so
ein bisschen durcheinander
naja wer an das hole ich so richtig
erklärt mit dem mit dem gutgläubigen
erwerb das eben quasi ein auch ein
falscher eintrag im grundbuch dafür
sorgt dass der grundsatz dass man
eigentlich an gestohlenen sachen nicht
eigentum erwerben kann außer kraft
gesetzt wird und man quasi an einem haus
das auch mit einem falschen eigentümer
im grundbuch steht eben doch gut das
eigentum mehr werden ja das wäre halt
hätte blöd laufen können dann hätten wir
die nämlich tatsächlich ihr haus los
gewesen und dann wäre es richtig richtig
kompliziert wurde genau also das eben
zum nachtrag und wir haben noch was sehr
schön ist das freut uns natürlich auch
immer wenn wir von euch wenn wir von
ihnen hören da hat sich ein hörer
gemeldet der jetzt eine mündliche
prüfung bestanden und auch eine ganz
hinreißende e mail war dass ich meine ja
genau das war sehr schön also der auch
uns einen gewissen anteil an dem
gelingen seiner möglichen prüfung zu
schrieb das freuen uns natürlich immer
ob wir obwohl wir dann natürlich auch
unsere zweifel haben aber er fühlte sich
jedenfalls durch diesen podcast sehr gut
vorbereitet es kam dran das ist
vielleicht für alle jura studenten und
studentinnen auch ganz wichtig was immer
interessant erstmal zuhören was so in
anderen prüfungen läuft da war wohl der
punkt dass darin vorkam die die
auseinandersetzung zwischen dem
bundeswahlleiter und forsa also der vgh
vgh kassel fall den wir besprochen haben
und was war noch später eine rolle acht
die ja die doppelbestrafung
die wurde auch abgefragt das war etwas
das war die letzte sendung der letzte
podcast.de nicht noch mit constantin
familien zusammen gemacht habe da denke
ich natürlich auch immer noch voller
freude dran war eine schöne podcast und
er hat offensichtlich auch was genutzt
freut uns sehr schöne grüße gehen raus
so und das war jetzt die hörer post und
wir kommen zum rechten ort
[Musik]
und jetzt kommen wir zum wunderschönen
gerechten urteil corinna gast und so ein
schönes urteil mitgebracht ja das ist
ein schönes urteil ist es ehrlich gesagt
aber auch ein ganz klein bisschen
tragisch auf den zweiten blick also hier
wie gesagt das ist etwas was uns
mehrfach zugespielt wurde er so auf
twitter so angebot nach dem motto guckt
euch das an ist ein
interessanter fall lustig empörend wie
immer man das formulieren darf es geht
um jemanden ein mann aus dem landkreis
stade der behauptet 102 jahre alt zu
sein und damit ein anspruch auf rente zu
haben
allerdings arbeitet dieser mensch als
verwaltungsfachangestellter sieht nicht
richtig aus vj 102 sondern eher sowie
50 also es gibt auch tatsächlich sein
geburtsjahr her also erst angeblich und
so steht es jedenfalls in den dokumenten
1973 geboren ja und dann muss man ja gar
nicht groß rechnen können braucht man
kein
leistungskurs matte gehabt zu haben um
zu erkennen da jahrhundert zwei kann
nicht gewesen sein und übrigens hat er
auch kein anspruch auf rente und
deswegen hat die deutsche
rentenversicherung
auch den antrag zurückgewiesen und das
wollte er aber nicht auf sich sitzen
lassen und ist deswegen tatsächlich vor
sozialgericht
gegangen und landete beim
landessozialgericht
niedersachsen-bremen die da auch eine
pressemitteilung zur ausgaben auf den
termin hinwiesen und das war wohl auch
einige presse anwesend und dann hat das
gericht was erstaunlicherweise gesagt
jetzt glauben wir ihnen nicht
ja weil sie sehen ja nun hier auch
wirklich nicht so aus wie 102 und
außerdem arbeiten sie ja auch noch und
daraufhin soll er dann gesagt hat naja
oder verwiesen haben auf den inzwischen
verstorbenen ex bundeskanzler helmut
schmidt der auch ins bis hoch ins
kreisen als er noch gearbeitet hat und
warum sollte denn nun eigentlich nicht
und so und dann und er hat auch gesagt
dass das er gar nicht 1973 geboren sei
sondern da habe er ihn irgendwie einen
unfall erlitten über den er aus
sicherheitsgründen nicht sprechen dürfen
und auch auf nachfragen des richters hat
er gesagt das muss ich hier nicht
erläutern sondern er stattdessen sei er
1919 geboren und da denkt antrages zu
werden dass es nämlich genau der punkt
wo ich meine auf dem zweiten blick ist
das vielleicht nicht ganz so lustig wie
es klingt also hört sich so an als eiern
und einer
ja auch psychisch belastenden situation
und
womöglich leitet er auch etwas schlecht
hat er als vielleicht hat er jetzt sich
auch ein riesenspaß gemacht aber das
wäre selbst in dem nicht weil sowas
fliegt natürlich auf und ist
offensichtlich und
er muss er nun auch dass die
gerichtskosten ich glaube von 1000 euro
oder so bezahlen aber also jedenfalls
ist das jetzt nicht ein sehr günstiger
spaß gewesen wenn es ein spaß sein
sollte aber es könnte eben eigentlich
auch sein dass er da einfach wirklich
sehr verwirrt ist und das ist natürlich
einfach alles ein bisschen tragisch ist
nichtsdestotrotz ist es natürlich das
gerechte urteil der woche wenn man kann
man muss sagen es war sogar noch aus
formalen gerechnet habe erstens das ist
ja schon die berufungsinstanz das war
das lsg das heißt er hat schon das
sozialgericht damit bespaßt und außerdem
hat er eine feststellungsklage erhoben
und da hat jetzt das lsg gesagt na ja
also du hast ja eine rente beantragt und
die wurde abgelehnt und da hättest du
halt anfechtungs oder leistungsklage
erheben müssen aber du kannst jetzt
nicht sagen ich möchte festgestellt
wissen dass ich rente kriege das ist
sozusagen prozessual einfach der falsche
weg und hat wohl deswegen schon als
unzulässig in der weise die frage ist
warum man mit dann noch auf eher
ländliche
mögliche verhandlungen haben sie
deswegen noch angesetzt weil sie ihnen
tatsächlich vorgeladen um sich
tatsächlich mal persönlich auch noch
einen eindruck zu verschaffen und dann
sprang es recht deutlich ins auge also
durch und durch ein gerechtes dass der
gute mann nicht er zwar immer noch
richtig sondern eher ende 40 und
womöglich eher ein tragischer fall also
das wie gesagt unser gerechtes urteil
der woche und dann wählen wir doch am
ende einer sehr langen sendung
angekommen und können aber vielleicht
jetzt schon nochmal verkünden und
locken damit was wir nächste woche in
exten so womöglich besprechen das ist
nämlich der koalitionsvertrag
der soll ja noch heute nachmittag
vorgelegt werden wenn man den meldungen
bisher glauben darauf den darf das heißt
da werdet ihr nächste woche viel zu tun
haben in der kommenden woche bin nicht
ich dabei aber ich bin mir sicher es
wird großartig werden und ihr werdet
richtig richtig viel daraus fuchsen
können herrn 6 prima ich wünsche dir
einen schönen urlaub ich danke allen
hörern und hörerinnen für die
aufmerksamkeit wünschen eine schöne rest
woche nehmen sie es leicht das ganze
theater da draußen und bleiben sie
gesund bis dann und uns eine gute woche
[Musik]